tuesday january 1st
1856 with little pride
and less hope we begin the new year
who is that good afternoon
i'm tally abigail
[Music]
i hope i'm not keeping you from
something i'm glad you've come
meeting you has made my day well how
pleasant and uncommon it is to make
someone's day
i guess i'm supposed to offer a toast
what my husband means is he's so happy
to finally get together
did you miss me yes
[Music]
our farm is a slaughterhouse right now
my husband is killing his hawks
and i resolve to visit you so that there
would be something in my day other than
his meanness
so what do you think what do you think
about us i don't know how to put it into
words
it's been my experience that it's not
always those who show the least
you actually feel at least
now seven an earthquake knocked down our
house we were born
an earthquake the dread never fully went
away
what was safe if the solid earth could
do that
when the day is done my mind turns to
her
and i think why are we to be separated
i don't feel i have a wife i have
certain expectations and you have
certain duties
we shall sing like birds in a cage
we haven't seen you for days have you
been ill
it's happening are you in danger i would
die without you
do you know what memory it is that i
most cherish it's if you're turning to
me with that smile
once you realized that you were loved
astonishment and joy
astonishment and joy
you